hey guys merry and Alex here gamespot at
e3 2015 and we were just at the
IndieCade booth and we saw probably one
of the dumbest games I've ever seen but
I just can't stop talking yeah it's dumb
and really the best way possible it's
called SMS racing and it's a Samsung
gear VR game that's right yeah this was
made by turbo button this a little indie
developer and they actually make a lot
of different things but they're trying
their hand at vr and they said they
actually made this before as just a
regular game like pc game but it didn't
have the right vibe so they made it VR
and what makes it so amazing is the
concept of this game is that you're
racing other drivers but you have to
text while you're racing exactly and so
this game becomes actually a kind of a
challenge because since you have a VR
headset on you're racing and
occasionally you'll get a text message
and if you don't want to lose your
friends you don't be rude so you have to
look down you have to look down your
phone and actually you know press the
buttons to text a message it's the old
school phone do so you member like Nick
now everyone has like a little keyboard
where they can type on a keypad but in
this game it's like that old school and
we have to like press down or left or
right yeah so it get your message out
it's always something really dumb so
like you'll be in the middle of a race
and you'll be in second place and you'll
get the little noise and you'll look
down and it'll say what time are you
coming over tonight and you got to
respond lulz in 10 seconds or less and
then when you look back up you hit a
wall and one of the best parts of this
game is the narrator which has it's like
super robotic voice I think you
described as kind of like the portal
nervous
this is a very dangerous concept that
they've done in such a light-hearted way
and I think that it's just incredibly
memorable because of that I do think
there's a long way for them to go in the
development I think this is something
that's just a fantastic idea and they
knew that they had to run with it and of
course I'm I was absolutely awful this
game because it's super difficult to
like especially the way give you our
works you don't really have much
peripheral vision so like you know
you're looking down you can see anything
can see em running into a wall spinning
out ending up having to spend you know
30 seconds trying to get back on the
course all I can see is like my little
tube legs and this phone and when i look
back up after saying something really
stupid like WTF or something so
unnecessary dude where are you seriously
seriously it makes no sense but it's
it's such a good use of VR and I think
people always say like what are those VR
games that are gonna change the way we
look at it like it's absolutely dumb
it's absolutely stupid and it's
absolutely fun yes exactly i don't care
that it's stupid i like playing it and i
can't wait to see more of it yeah same
here yeah well that's SMS racing if you
guys want to go check it out you should
it's amazing so for everything else
gamespot at e3 be sure to head to
gamespot com